[Music]
in money over love news submitted by a
David I saw a dude cool a Canadian
couple is headed to court after a
winning lottery ticket drove them apart
with that see money doesn't change you
it just brings the evil out inside your
heart already money and bring something
real you it brings up the riddle but I
think about the lottery and winning that
money I don't think about me actually
think about what it does for my family
and everybody else yeah I'm buying
everybody up what are you giving me I
said people I care about
so we first thing I would do would that
give you a big ass boxing glove so I
just suck you in the [ __ ] true because
earlier today I was like if I get 20 mil
I'm immediately giving you guys a
million dollars so you can so you can be
okay with me talking [ __ ] about all
these other youtubers and start ruining
JK because I'm gonna be honest about
everything it's not fine I [ __ ] hate
this person I [ __ ] hate this person
with this person because they're slow
they're [ __ ] lame and they're fake
but that'd be so crazy if that happens
and also in your channel blows up and
actually makes you another 20 minutes
and then I'll share it again I always
know whenever I think about me winning a
lottery I think about what's the most
fun way to give you guys your money no
you already told me my guess yeah you
had some pointless thing though you're
gonna give me kind of a same car yeah
you're such a troll yeah I would be a
tourist but the thing is on top of I'll
get your money II shouldn't have to give
you nothing at all I'm gonna literally
go around ask people what they want I'm
gonna get for him no that's ten car
payments that I have to do that I don't
well you already know what I won't
starts with the Honda ends with the
element I'll give you money on top of
that gonna give you random [ __ ] oh then
we're cool that was like the Oprah show
where people like yeah I want a car then
they're like oh [ __ ] I can't even see
this [ __ ] you know people that never
with a lottery though why because we
don't play no it's because it's it's
never like the most giving people that
want that win it you ever noticed that
Joe I don't get you like so many
giraffes thank you mm-hmm
still giving you the same thing with so
many of them - all drafts are made equal
just like dogs okay they're animals okay
get that right geo they're not they're
not inanimate objects giraffes have
feelings there might be one watching
right now at the Sandy there there's a
[ __ ] tear coming up to you I thought
you loved me man what how can you say
something like that
imagine a giraffe crying and then tear
takes like half an hour to reach down to
a giraffe would be your spirit animal it
is
got a long neck she's very tall and she
has long eyelashes what was that giraffe
cartoon you're right because what she
eats out of your hat she's got her
tongue oh yeah I just was a grad rep and
he's a gorilla hugging on her neck like
I love you so cute I wouldn't make it be
been things uh sure
and then you I would give you a museum
full of miniature stuff Honda which is
trying to be a kitchen with brand-new
braids David give them a kitchen but
lock everything and nothing works see
that's one big in will David every the
worst thing I'll get it I'll be like I
got you 20 Honda elements where
miniature ones like solid gold and it's
imperfect jewels and then you find out
it's fake and then you find out that
it's actually like expensive fake where
[ __ ] like it's just like it's just this
whole emotional roller coaster that and
then I would just murder you and take
your money and then we start the game
all over again like when I die give Gio
Bart 30 million 30 million 30 million
and then producer and that's perfect
because they would trickle it down
towards me I never get nothing you guys
are in the contract you guys can't give
him anything I wasn't gonna
[ __ ] with him oh yes you would [ __ ]
topic this couple of this Canadian we're
on that topic yeah sure Canadian couple
uh okay so the the boyfriends name is
Maurice Maurice forty you can't trust
them Maurice that's the name of a
[ __ ] capuchin monkey you don't
[ __ ] trust that [ __ ] capuchin monkey
chen the girlfriend her name is Denise
meet nah more recently same age corny
live Denise is this a joke Kevin it's
only I think a guy named Jean once Gina
would even Jean and Gina lame Yeah right
yeah I wish I dated a girl named ho
Josefina Joe and Joe Joe and ho yo ho
anyways back to this we're losing focus
sorry alright so so this couple
okay so Maurice and Denise they always
play the lotto together they like
something that they always do sometimes
like she'll give him money or like he'll
just buy it or like whatever they always
buy tickets finally uh this particular
lottery drawing she asked Maurice
Maurice like eight she has Maurice like
hey did we end up winning like we're
numbers picked whatever and then he was
like no he lied Oh Murray guy why is it
his fault he went out to go buy the this
particular ticket cuz it's sometimes
they do that like she'll give him money
and then you know he'll go buy
cigarettes and a ticket what if he/she
was mean to him and then when he went to
go to the liquor store to buy some
cigarettes in a 40-ounce he decided to
buy that lotto ticket but this time it
was for himself and not to share Oh
the thing is that they had always agreed
that if they won the lottery they would
be but was it was that boba yeah
or did they tattoo that on each other
like some Mexicans are they methane true
Mexican hey what's the [ __ ] y'all have
you heard of that girl tattoo to her
man's name on her face after your 24
hours after meeting him
what a sometimes you just connect with
people all right you never heard a love
bite you first sites yeah
what is the same thing no true love
though because it's true it's not just
love anyways I ended up getting married
they're still together oh I told you
once you feel like you feel like she was
cute and she got [ __ ] right here
[ __ ] passion nobody is worth tattooing
your [ __ ] face for that's dumbest
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you'll never be in love
David I am in love I would have [ __ ]
tattoo Muriel's [ __ ] mate on you and
vice-versa I already have it where
wouldn't you wear something Old English
between her shoulder blades that makes
sense yeah but a thong Kwan would you
know yeah sorry did you I wouldn't let
him it that's not our thing
yeah you guys are so unromantic I
wouldn't alright so back sorry I would
if I wasn't afraid of needles okay what
are you talking about I forgot about
that I don't ever want you to change
staying you forever and ever
yeah so Maurice lied about winning the
ticket he ended up quitting his job move
away
he quit his job five days after he won
the lottery he left the home which he
shares with Denis
the funny part here is that she was
saying like well now in hindsight
looking back like he did do like 15
loads of laundry right before he left
cuz he just left without something or
anything you just buy new clothes 15
loads they must wait a really long time
before they do a laundry you know to be
100% honest with you I don't own enough
clothes that I could even do 15 loads
yeah I did that once I did that once I
actually hired a place to come and just
pick up all my laundry and do it it was
80 pounds worth of laundry pounds I
don't have any clothes that's like a
tuna fish yeah so the wave Denis found
out that he won the lottery with because
okay maurices co-worker ended up
emailing the entire office that he won
the lottery and then somehow that's how
no second [ __ ] that's how she was able
to find out yeah why is this well
[ __ ] telling everybody yeah what the
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] I think we're focusing on the
wrong thing here I want to go back to
the tune of that way yeah that was a
really interesting measurement like
increment measurement that's very
strange you commit a measurement that
you decide to go with like see cuz
you're not paying attention to the right
pay attention to the correct [ __ ] where
did he go where did he go you do a great
job
I was listening teacher I said Canada I
know I love you I love you Maurice and
Denise sitting in a tree I don't know
where he went he just left her so then
when she found out that he was trying to
catch the ticket she immediately got
contacted a lawyer and then put an
injunction so he can't catch him - she's
smart as [ __ ] but then the lottery
people said well that wasn't even
necessary because as soon as we heard
that there were issues regarding who the
actual owner of this ticket was like
we're not gonna be distributing anybody
history wait what was they heard that
there were issues yeah just finding
reasons she's so [ __ ] dumb no she
actually had like she has a case here
because tickets I look at all these
tickets we bought together no I can see
how they would but she gave him money
for it it's not that it's the fact that
they were together solely in Canada you
have to be together for three years in
order to have the common-law marriage
that's it only three years I'm not sure
that is it so they didn't meet that
three year mark that's why right now
we're still like oh we don't know what
the final verdict is gonna be because
they were together for two years and a
half so were they married no oh they
weren't being also quite three three
years together means that you kind of
have the right to each other instead it
interesting that you live together for
three years
yes but no no no agreement they could
you could even be roommates that just
started [ __ ] well they're out there
they are also saying that
it depends on the circumstances as to
like what really classifies as
common-law oh my god that's course big
so that's what I just a lawyer yeah yeah
yeah how much how much was the money I'm
sorry so the total prize was 12.2
million Canadian dollars which is about
like 11 million so there were two
winners of this Oh hot so then the this
boyfriend guy is only entitled to 6
million but then if she actually can
prove or like somehow they grant her and
then she gets 3 million who cares just
give it a 3 million Shh he's [ __ ]
selfish there's a woman who uh her no no
she took off after they won without
telling her husband the husband suitor
he got all the money she got none
question you're with somebody for about
a year to have very loving relationship
you bought a lotto ticket without her is
that your money or is that your guys's
money along again you're a half that's
my good choices you guys are smart
people but you live together even if I
yes let this make any sense that's
Titans mom moola was it prior to
marriage together for four years
together ten years wait wait did we go
half on itself for me it's if we if we
put money to get it not go half on it no
[ __ ] that by dan you gangster Dylan I
mean I would probably like buy them
something really nice cuz I'm family now
I'll kick back a million or two you dick
well you're really nice I'm not kicking
back [ __ ] it depends how much I have if
I have a thousand million was that a
billion yeah just a thousand million
better you know what money's no object
at that point you're gonna get one
you're gonna get one you gonna get 1 mil
you gonna get 1 million hey Ron guys I
hope you guys enjoy the video please
remember to give us a big thumbs up and
a like like like and also when you guys
sign on YouTube make sure just kidding
news of the first thing you watch every
single day because we post videos every
day okay for more videos